- Like now what I spent most of
my time on is calibrating what
I know people are gonna do but
trying to figure out the timing.
- [DRock] What is the
practicality of timing?
(light music)
- Well let's start off
this episode properly.
Happy Birthday Misha,
I love you so much.
Seven years old.
I can't believe it.
Time flies.
My little princess, I hope
you have the best day.
- [Tyler] Trainer?
- [Gary] Yo.
- [Nate] Yo, sir.
And then we got to figure
out a room in the house
to put some of the stuff.
Boy, do I love the house.
- Yeah?
- It's the best.
What's going on?
Where's my team?
- [Tyler] Andy!
- I really want to
talk about video, Andy.
The Share Bear is not being
implemented in edits so for you
two I don't care how much you
hate it, it's learnings for me.
I don't care if you've got the
hippest fucking its like dirt
fucking street hip hop and
then fucking bear comes
at the last 13 seconds and
makes no sense.
Guys, I'm telling you right now,
here's the funny part,
you have to listen to me,
not the other way around.
Sometimes you guys feel like you
can sneak through some liberties
and you think you're doing own
thing and I find it very cute
and I laugh and I'm like oh
that's nice and all that but
then I can get mad too and so
on that I want the fucking
Share Bear in every video that
comes out for the next month.
I just want to see it.
Guys, this is Jordan.
- Hey how's it going guys?
(group says hello)
- Jordan's Mike.
- You got to eat these.
- Say hello.
Meet everybody.
One by one.
Staphon, good.
Zak.
Zak, good, Andy, good.
Brittany, great.
Andrew.
- I don't want to get you sick.
- Alright, appreciate it.
- [Gary] Okay, good. DRock.
- DRock, how's it going, man?
- [Gary] Alright, now
Jordan run it back.
I'm Gary.
(laughter)
- Staphon.
- [Gary] Good.
It's okay.
It's okay I suck at this.
- Staphon, Zak, Andy. Fuck.
- Seriously?
(laughter)
Just kidding.
- Staphon, Zak, Andy.
- [Gary] Brittany.
- Brittany. Fuck.
- [Gary] That's okay.
Andrew.
- Andrew. DRock.
Staphon, Zak, Andy,
Brittany, Andrew, DRock.
- [Gary] Good.
Sup Mike?
- [Mike] What's up?
- It's crazy I was just
watching your vlog yesterday.
- Is that right?
- Yeah, man. How are you?
- I'm real good, man.
What's your name?
- Jamel.
- Jamel, nice to meet you man.
- I said yo, I'm always walking
around this area, I'm like yo
one day I'm going to run into him.
- Today's the day.
- I've seen you're
around Times Square.
That's great.
- Been a pleasure, man.
I wish you well.
- Thank you.
- It's hard to get too
high for presents
when you get a lot of them.
- [Woman] Oh gotcha.
- I just freaked for one
wrestling figure for a month.
Just different.
- [Woman] We run
into that sometimes.
- Just hard.
You can't fake environment.
You just can't.
You can't artificially fake it.
You know?
- [Woman] Time with you.
- Oh, yeah.
But that's more foundational
subconscious stuff
that's later on. You know?
- [Woman] She'll only
realize what you're up to
and they grow older.
- Yeah.
Open the window.
Yo!
You guys workin'?
Yeah.
(laughter)
Alright so what's going on?
- [Woman] We are on a way to
Make Future Food Competition.
- [Gary] And so for two hours
we're going to sit there and
have teams pitch us.
- [Woman] Yep.
Teams are going to pitch you and
then each judge is going to have
the opportunity to ask questions
immediately after that team's
pitch before going
on to the next team.
- [Gary] Excited
to see the teams.
I like this format.
It'll be fun to see what
they bring to the table.
- [Man] Had you heard
of any of the companies?
- Every time I do this kind
of stuff I go in very blind.
Because I feel like
I never want
preconceived notions.
I want to be fair to the teams.
- [Marcus] Yeah, if you
believe in the pitch.
- I believe in the pitch.
I also find usually my first
reactions are always better
so I go in, I don't know anything.
When you do the
jumping jacks,
how does Ava know
that you did them?
The technology
element, is it an app?
- [Woman 2] Yes.
- When you say "we"
what is the team?
But everybody potentially has
that infrastructure now, right?
You're far more likely to be
discovered if you wrote your
article on environmental impacts
on obesity both in childhood and
in the work place on Medium then
if you did it on your own blog
'cause nobody knows
your own blog exists.
Have you guys thought about
making a Slack bot first?
- [Woman On Stage]
That's a great idea.
- Thank you.
(laughter)
Thanks for your time.
The thing that I think
really stands out for me as this
collective group and I think
it's something I believe in
tremendously is I think way too
many people spend way too much
time on their shortcomings or
the things that they think
they're going to be weak at.
I think this collective group
as I sum it up as a unit
what's very obvious to
me is for you guys to
triple down on your strengths.
When I think about Picnic, when
you're lucky enough to have a
business that has happiness
at it's core, there's a lot of
things you could be doing but
quadrupling down on that is
something I think all of us
need and I think all of you if
you look at it, you break down
from your backgrounds or your
day jobs right now have a core
strength and I think you get a
lot of advice from a lot of
people on all the things you're
not and I think when you really
look at the companies that are
succeeding they close all that
noise out and they quadruple,
go all the way down.
On their tech strengths
on their understanding.
So that's what I would say.
Congrats.
Thank you.
- Big fan of you.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- I met you a
couple years ago though.
- Hey.
- I'm Maylon.
- Maylon.
- One of Navi's people.
- How are you?
- Cool.
- Awesome man.
Continued success, brother.
- Thank you.
- I hope we run
into each other again.
Marcus, I gotta run.
Good to see you brother.
I'll talk to you soon.
- [Woman] You're headed
back to the office.
- [Gary] Okay.
(light piano music)
- You know, expand a little
bit on what you saw in there
about the timing thing.
I'm very fascinated by that.
Now I spend most of my time
on is calibrating what I know
people are going to do but
trying to figure out the timing.
It's predicting behavior
and predicting it's timing and
hitting that cross-section and
that is extremely difficult and
that's why the people that do it
tremendously win and get movies
made about them and
make lots of money.
Live their dream because it's
that rare to actually know that.
I think so many people have
ideas but they so lack the
ability to understand consumer
behavior and the macro trends
and what's happening in society.
Timing is everything.
Timing is, you know, you
hear that all the time.
And of course like every
absolute standpoint
hustle is everything.
Talent is everything.
Everything is everything until
you realize using a food analogy
it's if you're a great chef you
can take all the ingredients and
make something great it'd be
great if all the ingredients
were fresher, better, higher
quality but if you're a great
chef you can even take second
and third tier foods and make a
better meal than
somebody who is given
all those great ingredients.
So of course, talent and timing
and intuition and hustle and all
those things are imperative
but everything's imperative.
They're all a mix.
There so many
variables in success.
But timing happens
to be one of them.
One of them that don't
talk a whole lot about.
So it fun to was kind of
jam on that a little bit.
As I'm sitting here thinking
about it, it really makes this
whole journey of
DailyVee super worth it to me.
Right?
Here we are episode 40.
I believe the
timing is important.
I've learned from timing but
with all the keynotes, with all
the articles, with you following
me around for 40 days worth of
content now, here it is.
And that to me in a weird way
is why I have ambition and hopes
and dreams for DailyVee because
I recognize how many things are
deeply in here
that don't populate.
That they go
through ebbs and flows.
That hustle becomes a thing,
self-awareness has become
a thing lately. Right?
Patience becomes a thing.
But what are the seven to 12, 15,
29 other things that are deeply
ingrained in here that I take
for granted that I haven't been
able to figure out how to
populate from there to here to
there to here.
That's a challenge and a journey
that I'm excited to continue.
- [DRock] What is the
practicality of timing?
- [Gary] That goes in to the
talent of recognizing moments.
You know?
And that's so challenging.
I don't know how to teach people
to seize the moment when they
see a white space.
I believe Facebook video is
underused by most so
we have a meeting today.
I'm like, "Let's go. Let's go."
We need to pump out micro
fucking 1, 2 minute videos two,
three a day on Facebook.
We will win.
It is working.
It works.
My ability to recognize things
that are about to happen
is no different than a filmmaker
who knows how
to make the movies,
he or she knows how to make
the movies of the time.
Or music.
Who are the people that
understood that hip hop or
EDM was about to pop?
Or talent agents who are
like, "You're a superstar."
There is an intangible that is
very difficult to articulate on
why I understand that people
are gonna be all-in on Snapchat.
I think about the things that
I know that you're going to do
that you think you're not.
And you don't think that you're
going to be on Snapchat and
I know you're going to be.
I can't articulate it other
than the radar goes off
and I'm starting to learn that
I got to be more aggressive
when the radar goes off and
go harder, stronger, meaner.
And that's that.
(light piano music)